hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to do a before and after on
neck pain so you had a car accident
about how long ago I was in 2010 so six
years ago Wow
so tell me you were sitting there did
you see the other car coming no I was
looking into the review mirror and I was
rear-ended so I got way blushed okay so
when you're rear-ended your neck goes
back first and then with backs forward
right here so we get a lot of damage in
the neck so right now you've been having
a lot of neck problems right yep you
have pain and stiffness right that's
great so on a scale from one to ten I'm
sorry on a scale from one to ten ten
being very severe pain zero being no
pain how would you rate it right now
probably eight to nine now let's take a
look at the range of motion go ahead and
tuck your head forward okay that seems
to be somewhat okay yes okay now go back
okay so it doesn't go back mm-hmm so
your neck is kind of stuck mm-hmm all
right so look to the left
lift okay and the right good any problem
with that it seems okay okay all right
so we got a problem in extension now the
first thing we know that there's damage
from the whiplash so and I can do that
but I want to make sure that we really
resolve this thing as fast as possible
and of course I know that there's two
things that will cause a problem with
the neck one is the neck problem itself
number two is digestion okay I did find
out she has a lot of digestive issues
okay so we're going to going to first
see how much of the digestion is keeping
your neck locked up okay so to do that
we're going to do a little work with the
gallbladder so you can lay on your back
so we're just going to do a little mile
pressing over the gallbladder area now
what's happening the gallbladder right
here has nerves that go right up into
the neck and if it's congested which it
is
that's going to keep your neck really
tight
okay now we're going to press the other
side too why because there's two nerves
there's one that goes up here and this
this one over here and they're called
the phrenic nerves and they affect the
they connect to the diaphragm and the
organs underneath the ribcage and so if
your pancreas is working too hard the
gall bladder that can refer pain the hip
bones connected to the thigh bone and I
know this is uncomfortable so I'm going
kind of light
okay so you can sit up for me and if you
can sit back in the chair here
alright so I just did a little work on
the digest system and I want you to tell
me the pain where is that it now feels
relaxed actually I feel like that bigger
weight is off my shoulders actually I
feels great actually and the back
actually feels lighter Wow - so it was
at a seven or seven or eight what is it
now um probably a two - that's pretty
good now I'm going to move your head
back let me see what happens is your
neck okay is it going back up a little
bit better a little bit better okay so
we knocked out some of the pain now
here's the interesting thing
did you ever think in a million years it
was connected to your gallbladder or
your digestive system no yeah so this is
a going deeper into the system and I
just already have done this a million
times to already know it's connected but
what's interesting is that you can knock
out so much problems with the neck by
working on the digestive system and no
one does this so I'm gonna recommend
that she's already already found out
what she's eating she's following all my
video so she's eating good but I think
what you'd benefit from is a little help
with your stomach and the gallbladder
just from a nutrition standpoint because
if you took probably the gallbladder
formula and then outside a vinegar +
before you ate that would allow her to
eat more more complete digestion take
the congestion of the gallbladder reduce
this and your neck will feel better and
better and better okay so that's one
thing I'm going to recommend now we're
going to actually clean up some of the
injury from the car accident so let's do
that next I have to first differentiate
if the problem is in the neck or is it
in the shoulder muscles because her neck
muscles our shoulder muscles are like
really tight and so is your neck so I
need to find out what it is okay so I'm
going to stretch your arms I'm going to
stretch and you can relax your arms I'm
going to stretch it up okay so what I'm
doing is I'm stretching
the muscles right underneath her arms
relax your shoulders and I'm stretching
as a person is relaxing stretching up
what this is doing it's relaxing all the
upper back muscles now I want you to
tilt your head back see if it's any
looser yes look at that come back up go
back again look better so she has a lot
of muscle problems in her upper back
that are tightening the problem but she
was in a whiplash so the first action
was going back so she tore all the
muscles and the tendons on the front
part of her vertebra so we don't want to
do any stretching back okay unless she
moves her back the stretch you want to
do is forward so what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to stretch some of the
muscles forward then I'm lifting the
back of her skull up stretching forward
like just like that we're just gonna do
it like a few times I'm kind of
isolating her skull and lifting and
stretching the spine going forward now
the only time I wouldn't do this if she
was in a car accident from the front end
it's a real subtle
okay now tilt your head back and see
what it is now okay good
is that a little bit better okay good so
now the next thing we're to do there's
two collarbones right here and there's
two little muscles underneath there
we're going to stretch the collarbones
not the collarbones but the muscles
underneath the collarbones I'm going to
take my hand and she could even probably
do it with a massage tool but we're
going to show how to do it up underneath
here
so I'm going to have you tilt your head
back forward good go back and forward
forward good and back forward and back
and I'm lifting more time
more time
okay okay so let's try it again on your
on your own tilt it back okay seems like
it's doing okay so now there's a couple
other things that we're going to do
there's a lot of muscles that go from
this bone right on your neck up
underneath the the chin and this will
these are very tender but this is what
you can do yourself you can work on
these muscles up underneath the chin so
we're going to kind of stretch those a
little bit because think about it her
neck is being pulled forward she's not
able to go back so all this is too tight
so we have to do is we have to stretch
all the muscles underneath the chin
which are connected to there's a bone
right here called the hyoid bone good
it's probably very sensitive
okay good all right so we stretch that
now I already know one of the technique
if someone can't go back we go forward
we stretch them going forward so what
we're going to do is we're going to have
you flex your head forward as much as
you can good come up do it again
I'm just going to assist her just as
much as you can but just a little bit
more so you always stretch the opposite
muscles
okay good can you can bring your head
back up now do you feel more relaxed yes
I do
mm-hmm um go ahead and touch your head
back and tell me what it feels like now
feels better actually there's discomfort
yeah so this is what I think that's
going on you don't want to like do more
than that per day but I would definitely
you can do this on yourself give him
massage tool or your hand and you work
on these points right here that lit that
gave you a lot of relief in your neck
you work on your digestion
you can stretch these muscles right here
you can even take your head and stretch
forward like this every single day
what's going to happen just do that
every single day just maybe like maybe
five minutes and each day it's going to
get little better and better and better
and better because it's been going on
two years your neck is like so used to
this position but I think you can get
this thing back probably within a week
and a half there's some other things you
can do as well but I think this would be
the first step but you do have a lot of
tightness right here so like for example
let me just show you one more if she
took like a bar where she hung our arm
and stretch this relax your arm good and
she just stretched this arm relax your
arm I'm just kind of mimicking
stretching and we stretch this one right
here this is going to actually take a
lot of stress off our neck in fact if we
just did this go ahead and tilt your
head back and relax your arms see how
your neck comes back come forward yeah
okay good just don't do that in public
and mention my name is good but if she
stretches all these muscles it's going
to give her neck more more relief so so
there's a lot of things you can do but
that should at least give you get you
started and give you some relief and you
look like you're ready for a nap right
now but it just takes a lot of tension
because for two years your muscles have
been holding on to something so they're
fatigued so now they can finally
allow so she'll probably sleep good
tonight so does that make sense
you're welcome so your pain was a seven
I went under - what is it now um it's
probably closer to one now
I love it awesome yeah are you happy I'm
very happy thank you doctor
you're welcome okay go ahead and apply
some of these and put your comments
below